[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قمه النيتو تنطلق في
ليتوانيا في تعهدات بتعزيز الدعم العسكري
المقدم لاوكرانيا
ينتقد موقف الناتو ازاء عضويه بلاده ويصفه
بالمتردد والعبثي يحذر من توسع الحلف نحو
الحدود الروسيه ويلوح باجراءات مضاده
احتجاجات في انحاء اسرائيل بعد اقرار
الكنيست بالقراءه الاولى بندا في مشروع
التغييرات القضائيه يقلص صلاحيات المحكمه
العليا المعرضه تصف مشروع القانون
بالانقلاب على القضاء والشرطه تشتبك مع
المتظاهرين بعد اغلاقهم طرقا رئيسيه في تل
ابيب
استنادا الى قرار قضائي قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم منزل عائله صب لبن المطل مباشره على
المسجد الاقصى بالبلده القديمه وتجلي
اصحابه الذين يقطنون فيه منذ خمسينيات
القرن الماضي وتمكن في المقابل المستوطنين
من الاستيلاء عليه رغم وجود قانون
المستاجر محمي
في اخر تداعيات حرق نسخه من المصحف الشريف
مجلس الوزراء الكويتي يكلف هيئه العنايه
بطباعه ونشر القران الكريم بطباعه مئه الف
نسخه من المصحف الشريف مترجمه للغه
السويديه لتوزيعها في السويد بهدف تاكيد
سماحه الدين الاسلامي ونشر القيام
الاسلاميه الى اللقاء